today we're talking about coding ai and
security best practices
i'm piccola and welcome to this week in
cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news
it can be difficult to disseminate best
practices to developers in your
organization but this is critical
if you want to save valuable time for
your business
to improve this we are excited to
introduce custom samples in cloud code
our family of ide plugins helping you
easily distribute your best practices
directly to your developers environments
head over to the blog to learn more
about how cloud code helps developers
increase their productivity
to help organizations confidently move
their sensitive data to the cloud
google cloud works diligently to earn
and maintain customer trust
control and transparency are pillars of
our approach
to offering a trusted cloud we're happy
to announce that forester research has
named google cloud
a leader in unstructured data security
platforms
to learn more check out the blog posts
ransomware a form of malware that
encrypts a users or
organization's most important files or
data rendering them
unreadable isn't a novel threat in the
world of computer security
our commitment to being the most trusted
cloud also is an ongoing job so we've
created a post to share
guidance on how organizations can
increase the resilience
to ransomware and how some of our cloud
products and services can help
at google i o we announced the general
availability of vertex ai
a managed ml platform that requires
about 80 percent fewer lines of code to
train a model
and allows companies to accelerate the
deployment and maintenance
of their artificial intelligence ai
models
vertex ai is a single platform with
every tool you'll need
allowing you to manage your data
prototype experiment
deploy models interpret models and
monitor them in production
without requiring formal ml training
check out the blog post for more
exciting news about vertex ai
and even more from io if you want to
read more about these announcements or
see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud
you